so i want to start with uh i really
enjoyed this movie and i think that one
of the reasons is because
the second act didn't have something
stupid about you two falling apart and
then having to get back together i like
that you guys were best friends through
the whole movie can you sort of talk
about that aspect of the script
yeah i agree i absolutely love that i
think that there are certain tropes that
people feel they have to include when
the
when the project is about two women and
and
i think that we're at the point where we
have collectively evolved past that like
what is
i think thrilling to watch is when i see
friendship that looks and feels real to
me and my friendships are honest they
are raw you know they're kind of weird
they're quirky we have such a good time
together and i don't necessarily want to
see anything about two women fighting
over a man or women uh falling out just
for the sake of it because that's what
we do like i think what's really nice is
seeing really watching a film and being
presented with something that shows
kind of the reality and the depth of
female friendship which is when you have
someone who is in they are all in
even if that means like taking it to a
criminal level
and of course i have to ask you both how
much did you actually know about extreme
couponing because i knew about
i think i knew about it a little but not
to the extent of what i've learned in
the last week
i knew a fair amount i'll say i probably
knew more than you i learned a lot on
this film but my grandmother was an
extreme couponer
and you know leaning from her even when
i was 11 years old that they're in the
basement of her home it was completely
bare totally clean
but the perimeter had uh cut at shave
down cardboard boxes and inside each was
a different company's uh
upc barcode label and the um
my whole family was responsible for
clipping all of our barcodes off of the
soup and the toothpaste and the cereal
and sending them to her and she'd gather
a hundred of us of them she'd send them
to the detergent company and say look
what a loyal customer i am they would
send her five bucks and say thanks so
much for your patronage and
with those teeny tiny two dollar five
dollar checks she started college funds
for her five grandkids
wow yeah
wow
i i did not know and that is um
amazing and also crazy at the same it's
amazing like i you know um kirby i have
to ask you an individual question
because uh i am so excited about sandman
and i'm just wondering with you cast as
death does that mean that death is
british
death uh well i'm british i i don't know
that the um the sort of like
cosmic entity of death is is bound to
any place on this earth but i am british
so in this in this iteration yeah death
is death separate in this for this one
totally um i just had to i had to work
in something on that series i'm sorry
but getting back into why i get to talk
to you guys um in the this project i
always love learning about like the
behind the scenes of the making of a
movie something that might surprise
people to learn what do you for each of
you what do you think might surprise
people to learn about making this film
although we did it at the height of uh
covid really the height of cobin went
but like that peak where everything was
terrible and then we knew nothing about
coronavirus at all so we were just doing
all the things everyone had masks and
goggles and were six feet apart and
separated by partitions and some people
were wearing gloves and no more than 10
people in a room and every hour everyone
left the room and all the windows were
open and a giant air scrubber was
brought in and they scrubbed and turned
the air and then they lysoled everything
and then we'd wait 10 minutes and be
able to walk back in and shoot like it
was
the the reality behind the scenes
shooting in covid was
crazy it was crazy i mean the reality of
what it was is something that should
probably have a film made about it
because it was absurd at some point it
was it was it was truly unbelievable it
was nothing that anyone has ever
experienced before and we did it and we
had actually had a lot of fun doing it
which is kind of crazy because there was
a lot going on yeah given all of those
weird things kirby had mentioned this
before and it occurred to me that i
agree that
those weren't there's not those aren't
my first memories when i think about
queen pins like just the fun i had with
kirby and the filmmakers is what i think
about not the fact that we were in has
messages yeah
oh on that note i gotta stop i hope it's
a huge hit for you guys thank you so
much for your time